the socialist argument is that in a
different sort of system workers can in
fact elect management run their own
forms bring new products and services to
market without the need for capitalist
wood Bhaskar really want to live in a
society in which birth control is
available if and only if a majority of
workers votes for it business owners get
to impose working conditions that have
given a good alternative
most people would reject we don't have
freedom lovers under socialism so please
give us a little bit more assurances
rather than fake responses if it's
necessary would you throw people in
prison for violating your values okay
while people are getting situated here
welcome everyone welcome to the Soho
forum it's wonderful to see so many
people here this is a monthly debate
series that we actually hope hold
further downtown most of the time but
this was a very popular event so we have
changed locations my name is Naomi
Brockwell and as a co-founder of the
series I'm absolutely delighted to be
here as a guest moderator tonight for
this very exciting debate the resolution
is socialism is more effective than
capitalism in bringing freedom to the
masses in favor of this resolution we
have bhaskar Sankara who's the founding
editor and publisher of the Jacobin
magazine and arguing against this
resolution we have Jean Epstein who's
the director of the surco forum format
format economics editor and book review
editor of Barron's so really really
wonderful having you both here is gonna
be very exciting tonight so up now while
everyone is going through their voting
procedure I want to introduce to you a
person that I'm a big big fan of he is
of course part of the part of the
problem podcast he is a very well known
and very funny comedian Dave Smith and
he'll be providing a warm-up act this
evening can you please give him a very
warm welcome to the stage
[Applause]
is this on oh okay hey what's going on
everybody
come on give yourselves a round of
applause for coming out tonight huh this
is gonna be fun
socialism vers capitalism the great
debate of our time and I I am a free
market libertarian I just happened to be
a shitty dresser that's a coincidence so
don't let that don't let that throw you
off or anything
all right good they can take a job how I
don't usually you know when we do these
things it's usually very libertarian
leaning but now we got some free-market
people here some socialists but I think
we can all agree that Trump is doing a
great job so there's a lot there's a lot
that we come together uh-huh there's
like four people who took that literally
and then the rest of the forum a couple
were right there but you know hey look
we may have some differences but at
least we're here we're gonna settle them
peacefully I think an Tifa might come
any minute but I just I hoped for now we
can have some fun I don't know I heard a
socialist told me once that that
libertarians American libertarians stole
the word libertarian from you guys is
that is that true
because I there is right like in Europe
the word libertarian was more associated
with like left-wing economics and then
Americans took that but really liberals
took our word and then we took your [ __ ]
because we just didn't have anything but
if it make if it makes you feel better
don't think of it as a stealing your
word just think of it as us
redistributing it to a different class
of people who needed it more than you
did I don't does that make it go down
any better no probably not what I don't
know what else can we come together on
besides obviously our love for Donald
Trump
we all were all anti-war probably right
yeah there we go someone's excited about
that that's what I like about like the
Socialists at least you guys are usually
pretty consistent on that one unless you
know Obama's doing it but other than
that you guys you guys are great
whenever a Republican is going to war
you're usually against that so let's say
at least 50% of the time
preciate it Tahoe Donald Trump do you
guys like to the Socialists at least
enjoy the kind of burn it down aspect of
Donald Trump yeah I thought I thought
some of you guys might at least like
that right now oh when did you guys
become such [ __ ] I thought you were
revolutionaries don't burn it down we
like our iPhones now all right it's fun
huh the thing that Donald Trump's grab
people by I'm sorry did I not I should
watch my mouth on these things I
apologize
I knew the left wing was gonna be a
problem for me on this was that was that
a microaggression I don't know I don't
understand your language I'm - I don't
know maybe if I was younger I would
understand when to draw the line I'm out
of the game okay I'm married my wife is
here so you can't me to make all right
I'm out of this my wife is here she's
beautiful and she's and we're expecting
our first baby in in seven weeks
yeah that's how you get the left wing
off your back
what come on I would be a father I love
my wife she's incredible also I could
not be single in the me to moment
anymore I don't know how I don't know
how these young men navigate those
waters but I was like I got to get out I
don't you know like how do you even do
it if you're like a 20 year old single
guy you just like you go up to a girl
and you're like can I buy you a drink
and she's like actually I'm gonna call
the cops so that did and you're like I
don't think she likes me
I okay sensitive subject all right I
thought the shitty clothes thing I
should have gone back to that okay no
problem - some of you someone said they
did when I said the Donald Trump burn it
down think you kind of liked it nobody's
ever respected the presidency less than
now right at least that's that's
something and no one can deal with that
guy now you say I think Bernie Sanders
might have done a decent job debating
him did you guys Bernie fans know
all right they're not very enthusiastic
but they're there I don't you know I
disagree with most of his policies but
when it comes down to it I'm a New York
Jew I kind of love that guy like there's
just something there's something about
it
I mean I know he's in Vermont now but
that guy is a New York Jew to the core
there is you can't you can't take that
out of him I liked his style like I like
how Bernie Sanders debated Hillary
Clinton like like he just he debated
like he was just going somewhere else
and then they were like hey before we go
to dinner you got to stop off and debate
Hillary Clinton for a little bit and he
was like okay let's do it you know like
yours and they were like you want to
maybe run a comb through your hair he's
like what was the time I mean I like
just to go didn't even care I liked that
part Bernie sander
this may not make any sense but like I
feel like Bernie Sanders like when he's
giving a speech like he's just like the
1% and health care and all this I feel
like if you went on stage and just took
him and like moved him this way he would
just keep giving the speech this way
does that does that make sense at all
I'm not I don't mean to like I'm not
making fun of him for that it's just
like an observation but I'm a
libertarian I'd say about 90% of us are
somewhere on the autism spectrum so I'm
not like trying to if we cured or autism
tomorrow libertarian vanishes like
there's no more of us that's that we
just throw in the towel at that point I
don't know I'm very excited I am very
excited to see how this uh
this debate unfolds it is a super
interesting topic I mean no matter who
wins I hope you all that we will still
live in a neoliberal warfare state like
that's not going away it doesn't matter
how many good points are made up here
tonight we're all still going to be
angry that's another thing libertarians
and socialists have in common
we never win nothing ever goes our way
like Democrats and Republicans they get
to feel good sometimes we just always
have to explain why the person you think
we like still sucks and that's it's
exhausting
I do look maybe it's my bias but I do
feel like the socialism is a very I feel
like the hatred of capitalism I should
say is a little bit of a privileged
opinion I know I know
listen I I know you guys clap your ears
or whatever it's fine you agree they
don't agree but I just feel like look
I'm just giving my thought I think that
you wouldn't like I know abuse a lot of
you socialist you you hate capitalism
and it's excesses and you go to like
Times Square and it's just like this is
disgusting and I get it it is it's like
coca-cola and McDonald's as billboards
everyone's just like consumerism and but
I just think only like a privileged
person from a rich country would see
that like my point is no one comes over
from a third-world country
to Times Square and they're like oh the
consumerism like no one comes from
Africa and they're just like oh my god
the marketing is just separate they come
over and they're like holy [ __ ] food
look at this food everywhere this is
amazing I don't even have to hunt it I
just have to give you some of this paper
Fiat paper by the way it's not backed by
anything
I'm micro aggressed again I can't help
myself sir hi sir I really would like
you Wow
he just said great spiel let's have the
debate ensuring that I can't possibly
leave now I have to stay for a long time
I can't possibly leave on that I can't
let you pulling me off stage sir sir you
would lose a fight to my grandpa
you're not gonna bully me off of stage
okay you disagree with me I'm sorry if I
stereotyped Africa how about this for my
next comedy set you can make me a list
of all of the offensive subjects I'm not
allowed to talk about
then you can shove it up your ass okay
thank you guys very much you'd rather
debate I appreciate it
[Applause]
and on that note let's invite the
speakers onto the stage I trust that
everyone has already put in their votes
into the Soho vote.com website I'm
looking at it right now there are a lot
of responses here so thank you all for
that I'll be closing in just a moment
but let me go ahead and introduce our
speakers so arguing for the resolution
is Bhaskar Sankar who's the founding
editor and publisher of the Jacobin
magazine a leading voice of the American
left he's also the author of the
forthcoming socialist manifesto the case
for radical politics in an era of
extreme inequality which will be out in
April from basic books arguing against
the resolution as Jean Epstein the
director of the Soho forum is the former
economics editor and book reviewer
editor of Barron's and once more the
resolution tonight is socialism is more
effective than capitalism in bringing
freedom to the masses can you please
give our debaters a very warm welcome to
the stage so I am closing the voting now
for anyone who didn't get your voice and
just realize that in order for your vote
to be counted you have to be voting
twice so and Jean will be back in one
second this is the perfect moment for
him to be leaving fortunately
fortunately he has done this many many
times and understands the format so I
will go ahead and explain the format to
all of you so I'll give you a couple
more seconds to vote on there if anyone
hasn't already and so we start off with
a 15-minute opening remarks from each
person starting with the affirmative and
Bhaskar and then Jean will give his case
for the negative after that we have five
minutes of rebuttal from each side and
then I'm going to be inviting the
audience to ask questions so you will
notice that we in this very dark room
that you can't see them at the moment we
do have two microphones at the front of
the stage so if you are up the top in
the gallery I saw that a lot of people
have has since arrived and that's filled
up so I will be letting you guys know if
you wanted to ask questions to either of
the debaters I'll be letting you know
when you
and make your way down and start lining
up there and the same goes for everyone
in the audience if you do want to ask
questions to either of the debaters then
I will be letting you know that the
microphones are gainer at the side
please don't line up before I announce
it because we'll just have a long line
of people there so after that we'll have
30 minutes of Q&A I will also at that
time invite the debaters to be asking
questions to each other he's back guys
yeah this is what a bit of very
one-sided debate without your team so
after that we will have five minutes
closing remarks from the affirmative
five minutes summary from the negative
and then we'll open up the final vote so
now that that is all clear we are ready
to begin I would like to invite Bhaskar
to give your opening establishing case
15-minute remarks
thank you all for for coming I should
say I'm a bit wary of the framing
actually I was a bit worried about even
about even coming but I took inspiration
from I don't know if any of you are a
basketball fans I'm very excited that
the season is starting start inspiration
from Jimmy Butler
you know you might make a scene but you
got to show up to get paid so I'm here
so I am worried about the framing
statement because it's an assertion that
could very well devolve into just
terminological debates
you know I say socialism means one thing
gene says capitalism means another I lay
at a socialist vision of a just world
gene says I'm comparing the messiness of
an actually functioning system with a
theoretical one so instead what I would
like to do is both lay out the
democratic socialist vision and explain
how reforms inspired by it and enacted
by Democratic socialists have furthered
the cause of human freedom so to begin
with I should say that democratic
socialism is not an anti liberalism we
stand in the radical spirit of the
Enlightenment the spirit of those
movements that called for liberty
equality and solidarity the problem that
socialists have with capitalism is that
it's both created the material wealth
necessary for us to bring about that
world but frustrated its actual
realization so India has a free press
that's a triumph of its social order but
30% of Indians are illiterate to fulfill
the promise of freedom of press in
actuality we need to have the right to a
universal high quality state-run
education so that's a logic of
democratic socialism pushing beyond the
logic of liberalism so similarly we do
have freedom today we're not living in
the worst of all possible worlds but
it's an unnecessarily limited freedom
it's a freedom mostly enjoyed by those
who own capitalist private property the
rest of us are at the mercy of those
people by private property socialists
don't mean personal items but those
things that give people who own them
power over those who don't take it
privately
workplace business owners get to impose
working conditions that have given a
good alternative
most people would reject and while
workers do most of the work at a job
owners have unilateral say over how
profits are divided so Jean would say
that this is merely an employment
contract while socialists say that
worker starve is not a fair choice
economic relations aren't free and
private these are contrasts that are
laid under duress their contracts that
undemocratically give some people
tremendous power over others now
capitalists and workers of course need
each other but it's an asymmetrical
dependency any employer needs an
individual employee less and that
employee needs an employer the this
realization is at the core of
working-class politics the the reason
why generations of working people have
organized collectively to bargain on the
shop floor and I've also tried to
influence politics at a national level
through political parties now let's look
at concrete examples of democratic
socialist politics in practice examples
that I would argue show the enhancement
of human freedom in action so we could
see existing societies take Europe's
welfare states in most cases built by
social democratic movements where
private property has been undermined
through the regulation of capital in
those societies the majority enjoy a
greater reign of range of choice and
they have a greater chance to reach
their god-given potential than I do in
the United States before I'm an atheist
I'm not sure why I said God but roll
with it those societies limit freedom
for people that own private property if
I owned a factory and I employ gene
there's a restriction on my freedom to
use a machinery that I purchased with
any given set of workers including gene
for more than 40 hours a week that
there's a restriction on my ability to
unilaterally dismiss gene if gene isn't
doing a good job and within the first
hour of screw up I want to dismiss him
and so forth but for the majority of
people who don't own
private property for people like Jean
they enjoy a greater range of choice and
decided their life outcomes deciding the
conditions of which they live every day
and a greater chance to reach their full
potential
they had this greater freedom not
because private property is upheld but
because the freedom for the minority who
owns private property is limited
fundamentally socialists believe in the
rights of people to the fruits of their
own labor of course we believe in
individual rights and individual freedom
but our individuality can only be
developed fully in a society embodying
the values of liberty equality and
solidarity
we don't want an all-powerful government
bureaucracy we don't want big corporate
bureaucracy to control our society
either social and economic decisions we
argue should be made by those with whom
they most affect so libertarians can't
go far enough to embrace a more
expansive vision of freedom that's
because a deeper freedom isn't
compatible with a world in which a few
own private property and the rest of us
are at their mercy is to survive it's
not primarily a question of the market
but that a private ownership and the
disparities of that entails
now what Jean may say if he was as sharp
and witty as me is that what you're
describing is a social system social
democracy a system where much of social
life is taken outside the sphere of the
market where extensive rights are
afforded to working people and so on
that might have been enacted even by
nominally socialist parties but that is
fundamentally fueled by wealth created
through private enterprise a Democratic
Socialist would have two replies the
first is of the rights I've described
above where rights were foisted upon
capitalists and enacted in most cases by
labor based parties communist regimes
rolled on authoritarian coercion but
also but out of the great workers
movements of the 19th and early 20th
century also came profound attempts to
humanize capitalism to make it more
democratic this progress these efforts
all dependent on wealth generated by
capitalism but capital everywhere and
always has fought against the
implementation of democracy and the
expansion of suffrage and once we got
democracy capitalism has always worked
to undermine it to make sure that the
power was never helmed in by democratic
processes by engaged and empowered
workers while were capital is so worried
about working in democratic societies
it's simple they thought that if working
people had the vote they wouldn't just
stop there they would extend democracy
for merely the political sphere into
democratic and social realms as well
that's why all parts of the social
movement call themselves social
democrats for much of its history
capitalists actually underestimated how
resilient their system is we do live in
a democratic capitalist society a
society that's been made more civilized
by the efforts of working-class
movements but simply every one of those
struggles every one of those efforts to
humanize a system to bring it closer to
our ideals has been despite the
resistance of capitalist to say that
you're a supporter of capitalism today
is not to say that if you're in favor of
markets I'm in favor of a system of
worker controlled forms operating in a
regular regulated market to say that our
capitalist is to say that you're in
favor of private property the rights of
individuals to own firms and employ
people and wage labor Democratic
socialists don't think of all capitals
of courses as parasites it might be in
our rhetoric but in fact it's not in our
analytical vision many capitalists do
contribute not only their individual
talents but managerial expertise to
enterprises and they often take on
tremendous amounts of entrepreneurial
risk in starting new ventures the
socialist argument is that in a
different sort of system workers can in
fact elect management run their own
forms bring new products and services to
market without the need for capitalist
we can do so of course in a society
where the necessities that one needs to
have a good life access a childcare
healthcare housing education all these
things are guaranteed as social
right and not something prone to
accidents of birth or the ability to pay
a market price for but if you're
depending defending capitalism once
again you're not defending markets
they've existed before capitalism and
they will exist after capitalism you
were defending a form of social
organization based on hierarchy and
exploitation most of our lives are spent
in unfree workplaces a few corporate
ceos make decisions that affect millions
of people and this tyranny bleeds over
into other spheres of life it undermines
even political democracy the noble dream
of liberty and justice for all has been
frustrated by how wealth and power are
distributed by how undemocratic
capitalism is and if we were to achieve
a deeper democracy an economic democracy
the Conor democracy that allows the
majority to live freer happier lives
then we would see that capitalism is a
barrier to that advance at its core you
know I'm a Backstreet Boy socialist you
know III I realized I wrote what I wrote
is very close to Backstreet Boys lyric
as I'm reading it but to assert these
social sort the moral worth of every
person matter you know who they are
where they came from or what they did I
added the last part with any luck future
generations will look back at a time
when when life outcomes were accidents
at Birth with shock and disgust the same
way we look back on more extreme form of
exploitation and oppression slavery
feudalism and so on that have already
been done away with if human beings have
the same inherent Worth and it's up to
you whether or not that's that's a case
then they must be free to fulfill their
potential to flourish in all their
individuality in order to realize this
expanse of freedom we need to guarantee
at least the basics of a good life to
all and given the opportunity to thrive
these people can then contribute to
society and create the conditions in
which others can do the same freedom for
working people today however means
limiting the freedom of those who
benefit from the inequalities and hair
in class society socialism is not so
much about trading freedom for equality
but rather posing the question of
freedom for whom and I would argue that
socialism is even an extension in a
sense of freedom for capitalist every
little fiber of a capitalist being is is
lost and the effort to remain
competitive in the marketplace
imagine if what Steve Jobs personality
would have been like if you would have
been able to flourish in other ways
instead of just being you know an
[ __ ] call his dying day but it's not
Steve Jobs heart it's marking
competition so now imagine what a change
would be like for a young black American
to grow up in a society where they don't
have to settle for the worst schools the
worst healthcare the worst job or likely
to be subjugated the worst carceral
system on earth last point is something
I know we agree on I'll imagine what it
would be like for women if they were
more easily able to leave abusive
relationships or escape workplace
harassment with the help of strong
welfare state guarantees imagine our
future Einsteins and the vinci's
liberated from grinding poverty and
misery to pursue their great
intellectual and artistic work or forget
Einstein or DaVinci better yet imagine
ordinary people with ordinary abilities
having time after their twenty eight
hour work week to explore whatever
interests or hobbies director fancies or
simply enjoy the right to be bored the
deluge of bad poetry strange
philosophical blog posts that comedy
routines will sure be a sign of progress
every form of exploitation every form of
hierarchy from feudalism to slavery
onward have one seemed natural and
impossible to overcome one day I hope
people will look back at the needless
suffering in this abundant beautiful
planet of ours and recoil in horror
there is a different way there is a path
to freedom and I think that path
involves putting the market harnessing
the market by putting it behind
in the interest of human needs and
creating society in which ordinary
people have the freedom to control their
workplaces to own it to engage with
others in such a way that is not
possible
under capitalism when libertarians say
that they're defending a free system
they're locking in a form of freedom in
which we could escape as individuals an
individual worker can become a
capitalist but they're accepting that we
cannot collectively all reach this level
of creativity and freedom that being a
capitalist means in the society what I'm
posing is not the restriction of freedom
what I'm posing as a society in which we
could all flourish or reach our
potentials thank you
[Applause]
now Jane will present his 15 minute case
for the negative well thanks it's a
pleasure to debate this issue with
Bhaskar Sankara
Bhaskar became a socialist at age
fourteen and for me it happened at age
four I was a red diaper baby since my
mother was a card-carrying member of the
Communist Party and I have her FBI file
FBI file to prove it you could tell who
the FBI agents were in the party because
they were the only ones who paid their
dues on time and now at age fourteen I
distanced myself for my mother's Soviet
loyalties and adopted the vision of the
Democratic Socialist with whom Bhaskar
also associates socialist values are
still a part of me even though I've
abandoned conventional socialism because
I've struggled with the issue of freedom
I've recognized not just that capitalism
is more effective than socialism in
making freedom possible under Bhaskar
socialism the exercise of freedom would
be impossible but here's the good news
capitalism makes it possible for Bhaskar
to achieve socialism without tears
unconventional capitalist socialism that
will be far truer to the value of
freedom and to the other values that
Baskar espouses of equality and
democracy and my proposed route to
unconventional capitalist style
socialism will be a lot easier to
achieve than bass cars chosen route bass
goes to Tesco defines conventional
socialism in his essay will socialists
take my Kenny Loggins records his quote
socialist vision requires quote
abolishing private ownership of the
things we all need and use factories
banks offices natural resources
utilities communication and
transportation Orford infrastructure and
replacing it with
social ownership unquote Bhaskar would
therefore abolish private ownership of
the means of production which we do all
need and use although you can keep
personal property like Kenny Loggins
records now now let's define capitalism
capitalism is a system in which private
property rights in the means of
production are both permitted and
protected by law under bhaskar socialism
it would be unlawful for someone to
forcibly take you Kenny Loggins records
but it would also be unlawful to own
factories stores and offices under
capitalism would it would be unlawful
for someone to take your factory office
or store but otherwise the exercise of
property rights under capitalism
consists of a series of wide-open
choices about the way people organize
their enterprise how they pay themselves
and the goals they pursue Baska seems to
think that the only conceivable goal
under capitalism is the pursuit of
profit but that isn't even true today
just for starters of the nearly 30
million small business owners in the
u.s. probably about 10 million can
hardly be said to be pursuing profit
after they pay themselves as wage
earners servicing their own enterprise
there is no profit left over their
motivation is not profit but the
exercise of their freedom to run a
restaurant book store food truck grocery
store podcast blog or what have you war
the motive can be the practice of
religious freedom as with the Amish
Mennonites and acetic Jews or the motive
can be to live in a productive community
as with a kibbutzim in Israel or the
communal movement of the 1970s spawned
by the new left of which I was a part
the huge nonprofit sector includes
Jacobin magazine and the solo forum
basco and i commit funds to rent offices
and equipment from owners of that
property and we raise revenue
from a combination of product sales and
voluntary donations from people who gain
satisfaction by paying us to provide our
products as I believe Bhaskar recently
acknowledged publicly he is a capitalist
we are both capitalist and neither of us
is motivated by profit the point then is
that under capitalism you can run your
enterprise according to any of a whole
range of objectives each worker can draw
the same wage if everybody chooses all
that's required is that you cover your
costs which can be done through many
channels I'll talk about how Bhaskar can
capitalize on that in a minute in a
capitalist way but first let me explain
why freedom would have no chance under
his form of socialism for starters while
Bhaskar won't take on kenny loggins
records he will need to shut down the
nearly 50 billion in financing raised
every year through crowdfunding which
helps launch credit kenny loggins
wannabes he'll also need to outlaw the
many other private ways people raise
billions in funding to finance their
ventures and be prepared to imprison
those who defy the socialist law instead
economic decision-making would come
under democratic control so let's ask
how many muslim prayer rugs with the
Democratic majority of workers vote to
produce what share of construction
materials would a majority of workers
apportion to new mosques right now under
capitalism vegetarians and vegans
who together make up less than 10% of
the population have more options every
year what the majority of workers find a
need to produce vegan meat or milk
substitutes how important would worker
majorities consider hair products for
African Americans
Baskar has written that he wants
socialism to quote involve a commitment
to a free civil society especially for
oppositional voices unquote
admirable statement they Avast Bhaskar
but now imagine an oppositional voice
like mine that once the
democratically-elected planners to
commit resources to put on public
debates catering to libertarians who
support capitalism or an oppositional
voice that needs resources to publish
publicize the idea that the planners
themselves are corrupt will they really
back those who seek to criticize them
would Bhaskar really want to live in a
society in which birth control is
available if and only if a majority of
workers votes for it or would you prefer
a society in which private business can
produce contraceptives the Preferences
of a Democratic majority be damned if
contraception at every CVS and Walgreens
sounds better to bhaskar than popular
controlled he may actually be a less a
fair capitalist at heart or at least
he'll see why democratic socialism poses
a threat to the freedom he himself
treasures under capitalism the mere
existence of buyers like Muslims vegans
Orthodox Jews and libertarians like me
gives rise to suppliers of their needs
the litmus test of people who believe in
freedom is that they are willing to
tolerate the propagation propagation of
ideas and practices they dislike the
intolerance have no problem
welcoming ideas and practices they do
like as a believer in freedom Bhaskar
might have noticed the intolerant strain
in all societies including this one and
yet he wants us all to take our chances
with the potentially intolerant tyranny
of the majority to which we must all
respond no in Thunder the right to
private ownership of the means of
reduction is essential to freedom but
the freedom of course can be curbed by
repressive institutions and to a great
extent we're seeing that today but
without the right to private ownership
freedom doesn't stand
chance to begin with the throttling
under freedom of freedom under bhaskar
socialism would probably be worse than
I've described realistically that's
because most of us will not have enough
hours in the day or even any great
desire to closely monitor the detailed
decisions of the the democratically
elected planning boards the planners
will have to deal with complex supply
chains and must have the power to
reallocate workers from coops that need
to contract to others that need to
expand and here's why the planners will
have a perfect excuse for rejecting
projects they don't like the economic
reality of scarcity by scarcity I mean
the fact that what everybody wants
always adds up to more than there is
they can therefore reject projects they
don't like on the factual grounds that
the resources are simply not available
here's one happy outcome for Bhaskar
socialism those oppositional voices will
start asking for permission to solicit
funds from independent sources and with
those funds they'll launch their
products choosing to sink or swim in the
competitive marketplace on their own as
a lover of freedom
Basco will help lead the capitalist
counter-revolution to restore their
rights as he starts realizing that
freedom and private property rights are
inseparable
so crowdfunding will make a huge
comeback and a thousand other capitalist
flowers will be allowed to bloom I can
save Bhaskar the agony of going down
this route he is written quote workers
at all levels know how to make things
society needs that can run their
workplaces collectively cutting out the
middlemen who own private property
unquote so Bhaskar let's talk about how
workers under your leadership can cut
out those middlemen and build socialism
in the here and now by owning that
private property you could tap the power
of the average
the bottom half of income receivers in
the US account for one third of all
consumer spending and the bottom
four-fifths for nearly two thirds
imagine that Bhaskar could assemble a
minority accounting for just one-fifth
of consumer spending dedicated to
patronizing firms run according to
socialist values they would have a
consumer economy larger than all but a
relative handful of countries their
vision would be to create a huge sub
economy of interconnected firms
dedicated to socialist practices
Bhaskar has written that workers would
reject employment by capitalists quote
if given a fair alternative well
according to the Basque are then firms
owned and operated by workers would
provide that fair alternative so other
workers would join dedicated the
dedicating their savings and consumer
dollars to the worker owned firms firms
could be bootstrap through crowdfunding
money could be borrowed through the tax
advantage medium of employee stock
ownership plans there's also the
potential to tap the three point four
trillion in pension fund money currently
held by labor unions in the US and the
41 trillion held by unions worldwide
here's one's tractive a strategy the
profit margins of existing corporations
average 15% of revenue so the movement
commands so that if the movement
commands just 20 percent of the consumer
dollar it could target companies with
boycotts wipe out their profits and
acquire them on the cheap boycotting has
an honorable tradition going back to
Martin Luther King and Rehana Gandhi and
boycotts are free-market acts performed
by consenting adults by capitalist means
instead bhaskar wants to play the ugly
game of politics by trying to win voting
majorities to improve socialism top-down
through government edict my plan can
happen much sooner
since the minority will be all that is
needed to get the revolution going and
it would be a bottom up capitalist
revolution brought about people who walk
the walk rather than just talk the talk
we
capitalists could not object since it
would not infringe on anyone's exercise
of private property rights in capital
goods as a believer in freedom bhaskar
has no choice but to follow the route
I've outlined to build his socialist
vision in the here-and-now that was in
fact the goal of many of us in the new
left in the 1970s and we failed but that
doesn't necessarily mean that bhaskar
shouldn't try so VASCAR let's start
talking about building socialism through
capitalist means the only means worth
employing for freedom's sake now since
we know that VASCAR socialism the
abolition of private ownership of the
means of production is a non-starter
that it will suppress freedom since we
know that's the route the only route
that basco wants to go down this should
deal with most of his problems with
capitalism if he doesn't like the fact
that capitalists have too many rights
then boycott them organize you have the
power of the consumer behind you but if
he wants to talk about cherry-picking
socialist quasi socialist economies in
Europe that are fundamentally capitalist
then we can talk about that to the
Nordic countries of Bella's respect
property rights more than the u.s. so if
we replicate the Nordic countries we
will in certain respects be more
capitalist than we are now but bhaskar
again as a lover of freedom I asked you
to march in the direction of those of us
in the new left who tried to to to do
the capitalist experiment through
through capitalist means the the
opportunity is open to you so please
take it thank you
now we'll have five minutes of rebuttal
from Basco so from the outset of course
I appreciate jeans remarks for the
outsells I'm worried that libertarians
are losing sight of what they're
advocating for because profit is the aim
of all capitalists and capitalism would
not work a profit wasn't the aim of all
capitalist it's not their aim dividends
isn't the aim of all off capitalists
they don't want to necessarily all get
personally filthy rich but once you're
engaged market competition they need
money for expansion they need money to
guard against depreciation they need
money to develop new techniques in order
to be competitive in the market against
ur potential competitors all capitalists
need profits the search for profits is
what actually makes your system your
system works so I find it quite quite
dubious that that basic point is is now
lost upon upon libertarians now as it
relates to my vision of a just society
I'll break into both the economic sphere
and the political sphere and the
Piccolo's sphere I imagine that we of
course need to have a productive role
for finance in other words there needs
to be some sort of way to bring new
products and services to to market
because I do believe that there will be
a role for the market under under
socialism I basically believe that there
should be a bedrock welfare state
something similar to what you have in
Scandinavian social democracies so
that's the state that I mentioned before
we're huge spots of life Rd commodified
so basic social rights are granted to
people just by virtue of being born but
then those should there has to be a
sphere where there's market competition
underway where worker control firms are
competing with each other
and producing consumer products if you
want to create a new firm you'd be able
to do stuff without recourse to private
capital because there could be
state-owned banks that are using
objective measures based on
profitability and other other factors
maybe also incorporating certain
ecological factors like a cost of
externalities I decide what to fund what
not to fund but I see this largely a
technic
can be politicized process and the idea
is not actually quite foreign to even
certain forms of of capitalism in which
there are state-run Development Bank's
that are not run so differently than
private banks only regulated quite quite
a bit differently but essentially what
that's emitting is so there has to be a
price for firm failure there has to be a
price for inefficiency I guess the
difference in this case is that the
price for failure isn't going to be
utter destitution for the workers who
are controlling their own own firms
rather they'll be able to fall onto the
safety net of a welfare state and the
state could then try to encourage people
into new sectors that are more dynamic
through some form of like active labor
market policies yeah it's not a radical
experiment it's social democracy plus
worker controlled spheres and the
decommodification and role for
democratic planning there would be there
would be only there at the I would
imagine at the commanding heights of the
economy so other socialists have
different views but this is this is my
view I'm not asking you to leap blindly
into society youyou can't imagine I'm
asking to imagine Scandinavia and
imagine then the addition of instead of
private ownership affirms worker
controlled firms now I keep mentioning
this again maybe because this is a new
tactic of libertarians to just say oh
well in fact this thing that we've been
complaining about for 20 30 or 40 years
is now all of a sudden extremely
extremely capitalist and I don't have
time to get into the into the debate but
fundamentally the trajectory of actually
building what I describe as democratic
socialism has happened through the
creation of political parties and trade
unions and the seizure of this state so
in Scandinavian almost 50 years of
uninterrupted role in Sweden the Swedish
Social Democratic Party deeper modified
huge swathes of the economy and created
a large welfare state they were still
dependent on private industry they did
so largely through sectoral bargaining
between workers and capitalists now at a
certain point this system hit its
contradictions there's many reasons why
this happened but
one of them is simply that workers were
given too much too many rights they
started demanding things that capital
couldn't seed there was different ways
to resolve the crisis one was the
rightward movement of social democracy
reconciling themselves to capitalism the
other way was pushing for a deeper
richer form of socialism which what was
actually ironically because he mentioned
pension funds it was through a plan to
socialized the investment power of
capital through pension funds so we have
been pursuing that route pension funds
and other things are our route from
social democracy to democratic socialism
we were doing so through the state and
through the creation of political
parties so we don't need new left
communal fantasies or crowdfunding or
whatever else we have a clearer complex
but but proven route from the 1930s
onward that we've been pursuing as
democratic socialists around to our
vision of socialism
[Applause]
five minutes of rebuttal from the
negative well back in the 1970s basco we
didn't understand economics that well
either
the bhaskar doesn't seem to think Vasco
doesn't seem to think that he and I are
capitalists and he does even though
Vasco recently was involved as a as a
capitalist with the finding of a firm
Bhaskar
depreciation is a cost it it's a you you
don't make a profit by paying for your
depreciation you should learn that when
you you and I are renting offices and
they depreciate and the rent that we pay
has to pay for depreciation no
capitalist gets profits out of
depreciation that's a cost so you may
now we at the Silla forum and Bhaskar at
a Jacobin is bringing in new technology
he he's actually planning a movie he's
planning a book we're planning to expand
and we don't make any profit but
obviously we raise revenue for that so
this idea of VAS cars that you need that
you need profit profit obviously the
profit and loss system I believe is
indeed highly productive but it's a
matter of choice under capitalism it's
not something that it has to be imposed
on people if you want to run a company
that's profit-making as most people do
that's fine
but many many people just run their
businesses and earn a salary from it and
Bhaskar if they need money to innovate
or expand they raise the money if they
need to pay the depreciation as every
capitalist must they have to pay for
that too but they don't make any profit
out of it they just raise funds for
those things so please get your economic
straight capitalism is just a series of
choices private ownership of the means
of production to do what you want with
that private ownership now Bhaskar has
now used that ugly word state-owned
banks Bhaskar has told us we don't need
crowdfunding ok you don't know you don't
only don't need it Bhaskar I assume it's
going to be unlawful I assume you're
gonna forcibly shut it down because it's
evil because it raises money for people
to own and operate private capital you
want stay
owned banks and you said hey look we
have that well you know what that is
baska that's the ugly thing with
libertarians called crony capitalism or
I prefer to call it capitalism after
what my uncle Abe the socialists used to
call it state-owned banks of deciding on
and evaluating your profit potential
these state-owned banks are going to do
that and we're gonna trust them we can't
use crowdfunding we can't use any
alternatives my solo forum is gonna go
before these state-owned banks and
they're gonna be then if they're going
to be people with vision and they're
gonna be evaluating my potential it's
going to be a totally fair process and
if they turn me down I'll know that well
my my freedom has been conserved
well that is craft ilysm that's the rule
by elites now you mentioned the pension
fund deal in Sweden I'm talking about
the voluntary movement of people's into
socialism I am in a friendly way trying
to call your bluff what I'm trying to
ask you to do is to get consumers they
have enormous power well as I said the
bottom half control one-third of all
consumer spending I'm asking you to get
them to voluntarily do it and not take
away the freedom of people of Kenny
Loggins and Kenny Loggins wannabes who
do want to raise money through
crowdfunding
a venture capital firms who do want to
raise money of all the dispersed
information we have out there that
capitalism assembles no in Thunder to
your state-owned banks bhaskar now apart
from that you mentioned Sweden as though
oh we libertarians just lately learned
that their cattles well the Nordic
countries have been brought up and
indeed the fundamentally kappa whatt
capitalist when the prime minister of
Denmark said no we are not socialists he
knew what he was talking about but
Bhaskar what you are doing is
cherry-picking these countries you you
are ignoring Spain Greece Italy Portugal
you're ignoring Venezuela you're
ignoring all the all range of countries
that have chosen this route
you've decided ah the u.s. is going to
be like like like the Nordic countries
like the Swedes well Swedish Americans
live better than Swedes in Sweden and I
think that for example when it comes to
medical care will we really have
Medicare for all or we will we have the
Veterans Administration for all that
wonderful government-run medical care
system that's been that's turned into a
charnel-house a bureaucratic killing
that that's what can also happen under
such regimes but again bhaskar learn
capitalism is all about choices it's not
necessarily about profits learn your
economics and March in the right
direction toward volunteerism as a lover
of freedom thank you
[Applause]
so in a moment I am gonna open up the
floor to audience questions so if people
from the top honest up make their way
down you can line up in front of the two
microphones there but before we go into
the audience questions and while they're
making their way down I do want to give
our debaters the opportunity to ask each
other a question if you have any so
design yeah yeah so Jane if you wanted
to go ahead
Vasko in a recent tweet you wrote
capitalism is bad I told those workers
that I just fired
how's that for freedom now you have also
written that in your system of socialism
there will be worker owned cooperative
still competing in a regulated market my
question is this let's say that there
are worker on cooperatives having
trouble competing in the regulated
market and that these coops decide to
fire workers who are not pulling their
weight and to recruit other workers who
are more qualified their aim would be to
make their coops better able to compete
in the regulated market would you allow
the firings to happen well first of all
I never said that we actually haven't
ever fired a worker I mean we haven't
had to but we do have procedures to do
so through progressive discipline I
imagine be the same saying in a worker
controlled firm where workers are
shareholders rather than wage laborers
so in other graves there's a verbal
warning that there's written warnings
with points of action then there's so on
you know force that progressive
discipline it's very common
i I think that it's it is a necessary
part in other words there is both the
calculation debate issue that socialism
has faced but there's also incentive
issues and they both need to be
addressed and I think having firm
failure and also having some mechanism
for internal governments governance
doesn't involve you know progressive
disciplinary firing for for
inefficiencies would be necessary in any
market socialist system while we're
still living in conditions of relative
scarcity which we are today would you
allow a firm to downsize severely I cut
one
it's death if it's having trouble
competing yes of course I mean these of
course I mean the firms will need to be
competitive in the market the question
is what happens when you fail will it be
utter destitution or will you land into
the arms of a welfare state that will be
able to take care of your necessities
and then get you if you're willing to go
back into the competitive marketplace so
in other words we want both voice and
exit for workers we want them to be able
to escape the workplace as much as
possible - do you think that Spain
do you think Spain Portugal Italy Sweden
Denmark Norway and and in Iceland are
fundamentally capitalist countries well
yes of course they're ok they're all
capitalist countries I would say that
this we there there's three different
you consider in this in this simple way
there were social democratic movements
in in Sweden for a time and and in
across Scandinavia they aspired to world
after capitalism in fact what they
managed to do is deliver doses of
socialism within capitalism but while
delivering these doses of socialism
within capitalism they built towards a
sort of crisis and at this crisis point
the left-wing of these these movements
in these parties push for a way to
actually resolve these crises by going
beyond capitalism well a right-wing saw
the easier route and the more viable
route as taking a step or two backwards
and trying to restore firm profitability
and and and so on so I think the road to
more radical socialism lies through
social democracy and isn't counterpose
to it but what I'm interested in is what
these parties were who is their class
base and what they aspired to do what
they managed to accomplish and there's
good and bad lessons I think some of
those countries you mentioned were not
in fact led by social democratic
movements in some countries like in
Germany the welfare state was brought
about by christian democracy looked
quite a bit different in the u.s. our
welfare state was brought up
through a variety of ways but largely by
a social Liberal Party so it's
constituted on a different basis and the
universal welfare states of Scandinavia
so and do you have any question the
South Stream well I have a series of
assertions but I cannot phrase the
question no I will I will concede pass
go you can make an assertion and say
I'll add that to the end I would have
one very quick clarification if you just
give me one clarification and that's
simply that I think when we think about
a political sphere under socialism we
again don't have to make this leap into
this this crazy feature no one can
imagine I think it'll consists of a
bedrock of individual rights that are
that are that are guaranteed to all all
people freedom of speech and so on the
one right that is very prevalent it's a
major feature of this society that I
don't think would be given is the right
to employ other people in wage labour so
if you want a criticism it's it's it's
on that I think that in the end the
political so that's a moral and ethical
belief that's the ideological part of
being of being a socialist I will
concede is is is entirely ideological in
that I think that in a normative sense
hierarchy and exploitation are bad and
to whatever extent it can be mitigated
we should mitigate it
so some forms of hierarchy will always
need so if you have a small child if
you're a parent you wield authority over
that child that's acceptable
unacceptable form of hierarchy in my
mind but it's a hierarchy that's
mediated that's control okay so in
addition to that there'll be a political
they'll be representative democracy plus
certain directive erotic inputs but that
will be similar to what you have in
Sweden or referendums in California or
so on so you'll be free to have the soho
forum you'll be
to fundraise for other things as long
for the state-owned banks boom you
shouldn't get crowdfunding state-owned
bankers the crap Atlas Bhaskar what do
you want well if you engage in
crowdfunding today you don't have to do
it through a JPMorgan Chase you could do
quite you would have fun yes sure it's
not used to create an enterprise that
employs wage labor wage labor I see so
in other words if somebody voluntarily
wants to work for me at the Seoul forum
what happens and insists on doing does
that person go to prison so he continues
to do that to violate your rule
what happens then Bhaskar I if I decide
to go to you one day and I said I want
to work for the Soho forum for the rest
of my life and and I don't want to get
paid well I want you to provide food and
housing
what would you be allowed to again sir
an employment relationship like that
under this capital society
no what do now you just answer your own
question look capless at 15 consent to
voluntary actions between people you
don't allow that will allow those you
are a lover of freedom you're doing
double thing you hate freedom people
should not do voluntary acts people want
to work for me that want to work for you
don't you have employees but aren't you
accomplice with employees no I'm
actually not even I'm a technically an
employee of a Board of Directors but you
know I work so in other words what I'm
saying is that the employment
relationship under capitalism is already
regulated I'm posing a symbol I a
relationship in which this this thing
wage labour is no longer allowed don't
you realize that you've backed away from
my question if somebody voluntarily
wants to work for me for what I pay and
under my and says I want to do it you're
gonna throw that person in prison if
that person does it against your wishes
and values is that what you're gonna do
how are you going to enforce your rules
Bhaskar how is that gonna happen well I
think that in a society in which most
people can do similar labor to what
you're describing but actually be
shareholders actually own
shares and receive dividends from a firm
I'm not sure they would choose to to do
that well I I think I directly answer
your question well that's why I'm
calling your bluff Bhaskar I'm trying to
suggest to you that you can work on that
and you can achieve it you could have
worker owned firms in under capitalism
any time you want just get people to be
impressed by your values there wasn't
just walk the walk and quit talking
there was mass there was mass support
for the for the minor pension funds
Creed there were mass support for the
minor plan in Sweden it would have so
slowly socialized production again
Bhaskar you are a political a Politico
you can't talk the talk of individuals
of individual movements you want
top-down either
I'm trying to tell you quit playing the
ugly game of politics but because that
can give you Donald Trump I'm trying to
suggest to you try to impress the
grassroots with your values and then
organize them the way King did the way
Mahatma Gandhi did and and then owned
firms and boycott them and take them
over work it from the bottom up Bhaskar
because your lover of freedom so you you
said this is what happens when you don't
let him I don't know but you said you
said that the pathway is through
consumer power and boycotts right and
where does your consumer power come from
okay if not the amount of money you have
which is a result of battles about
winners of our launch of economics one
third of the consumer dollar comes from
the bottom half nearly two thirds comes
in the bottom four fish repeat that
after me Bhaskar because apparently it's
something you don't know learn some
economics
[Applause]
okay well Jim you're just encouraging
men let's let's get to the audience in a
second I do in a more monetary stage
right I'm talking about the United
States
the revolution now I going to go to
audience question sorry what all right
so over here are this gentleman in the
front you want it I'll go ahead and ask
your first question you can address
either of the debaters can we turn that
microphone on if it's not already by the
way I really appreciate the be passion
up here is this not entertaining the Q&A
I'm very excited to see what what
happens all right go ahead not mark mark
Skousen I'd like to get your take on
both of you on John Mackey's book
conscious capitalism where he develops
the stakeholder philosophy of working
together and this is wholefoods the CEO
of Whole Foods where they have teams
that make decisions on salaries of these
employees so you have a form of social
democracy or democratic capitalism
already in the conscious capitalism
model stakeholder philosophy I'd like to
get your take on that new approach to
capitalism this is a question for both
the debaters socialists way back one
push at a time so I would say there's
different ways to organize capitols
workplaces some could be extremely
hierarchical some could be more
horizontal my objection to the Capitals
a workplace is the fact that it's it's
privately owned by by individuals and it
inherently relies on a form of
exploitation I don't mean to describe a
literal labor theory of value my quick
thing that I'm saying but rather that
it's a good framework to understand how
this works simply if if gene is employed
by me I'm not sure I would based on his
temperament but he might be might be a
true great union organizer he might be a
rabble rouser
but and and he's stable employed for for
ten years by me and I'm paying in
fifteen dollars an hour over the course
of this ten years then you could
probably assume one thing based on that
relationship that jeans probably worth
more to me than you know than the $15 an
hour I'm I'm paying him and we're gonna
have certain battles over how much money
is gonna be be paid and and this is this
is the the root of a lot of the
pressures that existed every workplace
you know people want to get paid more
they know there's certain limits and
what they could get paid in other words
gene can't them at a hundred dollars an
hour because if my firm is no longer
profitable then none of us are employed
but but there's you know there's this
tension that exists in all workplaces
they certainly exists at Whole Foods
where there has been worker actions
where people are demanding kind of
different things but the main thing
they're demanding is higher wages and
more autonomy and no capitalists no
matter how conscious they are gonna is
gonna give that to them it's gonna be
the result of a political battle on the
shop floor it's not gonna be you know
decided by a theory or ideology of this
first and a capitalism of that version
of capitalism well in answer the
question certainly John Mackey's idea of
conscious capitalism is is better than a
lot of other ideas it seems to work well
at Whole Foods and I support it I don't
know if it's valid for all firms I can
want to observe that VASCAR lives at
least granted that if he was a
capitalist and I was a worker he'd be
afraid of me even though I would just be
a worker so clearly there might be other
kinds of relationships that workers and
employees can have and again VASCAR
keeps ducking the two questions which is
why doesn't he create worker owned firms
if he doesn't like the firms owned by
handful of people that's quite possible
under this capitalism and would he
actually throw in prison people who
violate his values who choose to work
for fell through for capitalist firms
voluntarily Eve
though as I've said his quasi socialist
alternative would be available he ducks
that question as well someday hopefully
tomorrow he'll face those two questions
and see the light thank God okay next
question over here and just a reminder
if you're asking a question from the
floor don't give us statements make sure
that you're asking questions and keep it
short so my name is Jenny Brown um so I
wonder if both the speakers could
address the situations that we see on
the shop floor in for example production
companies in the US where it's no
degrees of freedom you have you're given
three minutes to urinate once a day
sometimes you have to wear diapers on
the line because you will be fired if
you go there are no choices about
whether you can have work overtime you
have to or you will lose your job so
just the the situation that is existing
right now under capitalism with private
ownership if you could just address the
working conditions that that is kicking
up and what percentage of workers do you
think work under those circumstances
about 20 percent 20 percent and yeah you
said in that's who are not allowed to
renew yes do not you know do you know we
don't even have 20 percent of the
workers in factories to begin with but
20 percent no not just factories some
schoolteachers have to bring their whole
class into the bathroom so that they can
pee oh right okay then all right okay
that's good
good to know I had to run out to pee
myself recently as you know so I have
two ties with that I'm sorry for this
stupid joke so best though do you want
to answer that or should I that's a
great job so far I mean they let you
keep gone well we have we have an
educational system that pays that that
pays nationwide ten thousand dollars a
student in New York it's twenty thousand
dollars a student so and that means that
for every 30 kids in a class in New York
there's 600 thousand dollars that could
be realized how much of it ends up in
the classroom nationwide there's 300
thousand dollars that could be realized
the schools are run by government
bureaucracies so that may explain why
despite the fact that there is that
that's spending on schooling in this
country is that a record high in
inflation-adjusted terms that may
explain why the problem that you've
suggested that you've talked about
exists that we may want to free it up
from government control and that's the
reason why poor people poor people are
over subscribing the charter schools and
the end of out your schools because they
spend their money so that kids do not
have to pee in the hole that's that's
the capitalist alternative which by the
way 15 percent of Swedish parents send
their kids to voucher schools and now
the other part of it is that oh you
should join with me as should Bhaskar in
trying to combat that the capitalism in
the labor markets to free the labor
market so that laborers have
alternatives government control on
behalf of special interests of some of
so many professions is locked up to be a
beautician to be a florist to be a
plumber do you know how difficult it is
to become a plumber in New York because
of the states afforded plumbers Union
all of those alternatives should work
should open up for laborers but they are
closed because unfortunately people like
Vasco thinks that government control
cadet all this credentialism and all
these barriers that make it difficult
for laborers to shop around
to get better jobs to work under better
working conditions are closed off to
them
that's the evils of capitalism that we
live in chairs are trying to fight and
that you should fight also so with
respect to the schools what you should
really fight really do is liberate all
of that money so that the $300,000
average can get into that classroom and
the kids the big peeing on gold-plated
urinals so the actual question was about
the conditions of huge segments of
American of American workers and it I
don't know the exact figure but it is it
is a large segment of American workers
and increasingly precarious jobs working
in factories with very limited rights
and the simple reason why it's like that
is because American unions are weaker
than its counterparts anywhere else in
the advanced capitalist world therefore
may American workers have the same
rights and are afforded the same dignity
as workers a very weak bargaining power
in the third world often and that's
that's that's a real reason and and if
you want to give people more rights if
you want to build union rights to say
that ok everybody deserves a five-minute
break every hour you know or whatever
whatever else is a very bare-bones
basics you have the very least fight for
the right to collectively bargain you
have to fight for the sort of
legislation that libertarians that big
capitalists that small capitalists
all have historically opposed and and my
only aside is on jeans two questions on
answer very quickly at a yes or no way
one is worker owned firms under
Capitol's and we're fine but they're
subjected to a lot of the same pressures
competitive pressures as as other as
other firms so we want to build a
society in which you have the bedrock
dica modifications that I talked about
where we have Medicare for all where we
have a certain basic education rights
and and so on so that's most of our
reform efforts are focused there seems
to you bhaskar then let me try to make
the same point the bottom half has asked
control of one third of the total
consumer dollar can
Zoomers spending could be dedicated to
those socialist firms and support them
in whatever way you want nearly 2/3 is
controlled by the bottom four-fifths
please learn some economics about the
power of the consumer that you can
marshal that could be a sub economy of
socialist firms and you could subject
them to whatever a economy of of
cooperatives that are thriving in places
like Spain Mondragon is a large
cooperative at one time was the sixth
largest business in in in Spain but
these these are subject to a lot of the
same a lot of the same competitive
pressures so I think in other words is
the difference between a cooperative
under capitalism and a worker controlled
firm under a post capital society where
capital no longer holds a power to
withhold investment where there's not a
separate class of people continually
trying to undermine refer reforms again
you're beating a hasty retreat you're
beating a hasty retreat just some
example about me what I'm trying to do
is trying to suggest to you the
potential in the American economy what
you can do we and the new left in thank
you so we didn't look at what others had
done badly we try to look at the
potential of what we can do look it in
the face and you'll see that let me
finish my answer your second question
please Jeanne you're from the new left
do you smoke weed in the 60s are you
wondering whether that explains well I'm
just saying that maybe maybe it's time
to get get back on it you know
so but on the second question no I don't
think I don't think I don't think
coercion would be would be necessary
well but but it's a process like that I
like that is necessary rasca would you
apply it what if people voluntarily
decide to work in conditions that you
don't like and they say no I want to do
it and then you said well you have to
stop doing no I can't stop doing it what
would you though then Bastar the it
would look the problem you are facing is
that we have the awful experience of
socialist societies most recently the
experiment of socialism in Venezuela
most recently what happened in China
that we don't have freedom lovers under
socialism so please give us a little bit
more assurances rather than vague
responses if it's necessary which you
throw people in prison for violating
your values the values which it's not
we're not writing a blueprint for there
for the future it's fine if I'm in
charge of a social society then of
course not
you know what exactly exactly that's why
I said it there'll be a social there'll
be a judicial system that'll have
certain criteria for when it throws
people in prison and all certain
criteria for what speech is allowed and
what's not and it will probably draw on
existing types of jurisprudence so for
example clear and present danger you
know it's not it's not a leap into the
unknown own future it's not as your zero
break with with the past we're saying
that there are certain spheres of life
that are right now only available that
people could pay but should be available
to everyone as part of their basic needs
we're saying that there are certain
forms of exploitation and oppression
that exists the world today that we
think we construct a society where it
doesn't exist
full-stop I think you said you would not
shut down a crowdfunding and that's good
to hear and and I think actually if you
ran the society bhaskar you'd very
quickly lead the capitalist
counter-revolution because you would get
sick and tired of those state-owned
banks that that are not granting people
opportunities yet that's what you would
do my
however Bhaskar is that maybe somebody
like you will not be in charge maybe the
best maybe the worst will get on top
maybe power-hungry people will but if
you were in charge
socialism won't last a month because you
would find how hateful it is because
you're a lover of freedom and we'll go
to the next audience question over here
this one's for Bhaskar although maybe
both chime in if there's time it would
be hard to stop him and to that point in
solidarity with Bhaskar I would support
state subsidized acupuncture session for
Eugene immediately following this event
sorry I'm sorry in 2017 the average
top-20 CEO comp was 66 million versus
the comparable average comp four for the
top 20 athletes of 62 million it's a
difference of about 6% those numbers
include options and bonus for CEOs and
include sponsorship pay for athletes
which group do you think creates more
positive value and prosperity for
society and do you think athlete
compensation and by extension celebrity
compensation which is very similar to
those levels deserve as much public
scrutiny as CEO pay I would say no I
don't even support a salary cap in
sports these are athletes that are
creating value and they should be renew
marae today they're creating they're
creating the value through their own
efforts and their own individual talents
and they're not creating value through
the labor of others so I think LeBron
James should be making many times more
than he was what he's earning now and at
the very least but obviously you know
he's collectively working on a team and
the point of any good collective
bargaining agreement is sometimes to
boost the conditions of the worst paid
or worst condition
players so in this case NBA players and
the G League and sometimes that means
kind of caps on on the the best-paid but
that's a collective democratic decision
that actually LeBron James was the you
know major figure in the players you
should point out the NBA players agreed
to the salary cap that they exact
underwriters collectively collectively
bargained yes not random I mean the
premise of your response is sort of that
it's random it's not random yeah yeah
yeah so the cap it said we don't need to
get sucked in I'm not worried about the
amount of money or the amount of wealth
that anyone wants that anyone got gets
it as a result of their exceptional
talent or ability obviously this is a
small percentage of society and also
that I think my conception of class is
not it's more relational than gradation
'el so in other words you could be a
capitalist and run a small firm of four
or five people and be struggling and
earn $30,000 a year or you could be a
worker in at a privileged sector or a
very capital-intensive sector like a
longshoreman and earn $90,000 a year and
I would consider one a worker and one
you know as some sort of small
capitalist yeah those are just two quick
observations those $30,000 capitalists
who were indeed legion with the people I
spoke about they are not they are not in
it for profit that's just simply drawing
a wage out of their business that pays
them for the services to their business
that's why that's another good example
of why not even today as private
ownership of the means of production
always pursued for profit again vascular
anionic capitalist the only thing I
would say to your question about
athletes are that again the crapola
system the the ways in which labor
mobility is limited which indeed it's
also limited by unions and the crapola
system whereby profits are privatized
and losses are socialized the best
example of that was Obama's bailout of
General Motors and Chrysler
again socializing losses which shafted
our workers in the south and favored
unions in Michigan because he was
courting the Michigan vote that's
capitalism and in the sports case the
the capitalism of government subsidizing
sports stadiums for these very rich
firms is this is an obviously an outrage
that VASCAR should also oppose up until
the 1950s the team's paid for their own
stadiums I'm a big James Dolan fan so I
won't oppose a great leader even people
it's okay with you all right next
question from the audience thank you my
name is Ray Harry yes I want to first
make an assertion and that assertion is
that your praise your assertion in the
form of a question well yes it's good
it's gonna be in a question yes it is
have to start over now I was interrupted
okay so the assertion is that it is
competitive capitalism that is creating
something an externality called global
warming and global warming is
threatening our very survival on this
planet
capitalism is responsible for this
capital it is competition competition
where all of us are competition creates
winners and losers and in this case this
externality is going to be such a losing
proposition for all of us that the human
race is going to be out of here and my
question is how do you address the issue
of competition creating such negative
situations for it automatically
structurally creates winners and losers
competition does it creates winners and
how does it create it creates bad
externalities what is your response to
this the one particular bad externality
is that competition creates
Vaska you had structurally looser so to
play to play devil's advocate in the
scenario just coming over to my side
that's good yeah to to turn the scenario
you played out you could find ways to
price in you know some of these these
effects through carbon taxing or whatnot
but I think as a whole the reason the
reason why capitalism creates these sort
of problems is less the market
competition end of it but the fact that
that grower died imperative of
capitalist firms isn't isn't restrained
I also would argue that under socialism
as I envisioned it where the consumer
sector for consumer goods is by worker
owned firms the same imperative doesn't
actually apply right because you're not
trying to maximize total revenue you say
you're not building these mega firms
what you're trying to do is maximize a
revenue per shareholder revenue per per
worker so you you might you know want a
firm of 4050 people which which would
solve part of that but I think in
general a society in which there is a
more robust responsive state where there
is a greater role for for elements of
planning and organizing certain aspects
of the economic plan of society which by
the way sounds very pernicious and scary
for those of you in the room that are
libertarians but most societies have
actually had industrial industrial plans
at one point another developing states
have all done at all within a capitalist
framework I think that kind of society
with more room for democracy and and
empowerment of ordinary people is
obviously going to be able to think
about the medium and long term effects
of of growth and development well I
think I think Bhaskar atleast did say
that that obviously you can have carbon
taxes you can rein it in clearly it's
not it's not capitalism that causes
global warming
it's industrialism and the the the the
Soviet Union was not capitalist it was
massively polluting
China competing with the United States
okay so that's why they did it okay all
right well quit well III think as Baskar
would agree and I don't have to disagree
with you I'd have to say that that
industrialism which involves the use of
fossil fuels it involves the it involves
the the heavy machinery involves all
kinds of things that that produce output
and under basco socialism they might not
want to wrap basket maximize revenue as
I just said under capitalism you don't
have to maximize for profit but if
you're going to put out stuff that
that's that's based on a fossil fuel
economy you're going to pollute and of
course they're ways of dealing with it
do you want to you are you saying that
the use of fossil fuels only happens
under capitalism sir no okay okay then
no that's good thank you answer my
question then the use of phosphorus is
what's polluting what's causing a woman
well no I I think it is true that that
under system like like capitalism
economic power does translate into into
political power and there are certain
lobbies preventing the emergence of new
technology but more important is the
fact that green renewable technology
there is a cross there is a cross cost
curve involved and I think that a more
proactive government pushed industrial
policy could could bring about an energy
transition and quicker I mean this is
not a rest well we needed Obama to
subsidize Solyndra because because but
but because we needed more capitalism
and again again basco talks about those
wonderful state-owned banks that really
scares me when he uses the word state
usually I didn't want to use that word
for Bhaskar because because usually they
like to say no no no that's the state
it's gonna be democratic councils
state-owned banks or capitalists and it
really depresses me that Bhaskar to lose
himself into thinking that those
state-owned banks will be the only place
we can go
- to raise money for the Soul form well
I think I think it is funny that gene
can summon the depths of the Gulag be
tougher wounds killing fields but
instead he's focusing on the North
Dakota
you know State Development Bank the
gentleman is yeah but you're saying
state-owned banks of this great
pernicious evil but you're not even if
you want if you want to abolish
everything other than state-owned banks
then you are going to suppress freedom
and the state-owned banks are not are
not the gulag they're not the pernicious
freedom but they're just a bunch of
people who are giving other people's
money away they're not putting money at
risk they are crapulous
they are not capitalist they are
obviously not what we want we want
crowdfunding you're not gonna bones
crowdfunding I thought you said 50
billion dollars a year of it you're not
going to abolish it I think if you were
going to make if I was gene I was gonna
make a case against democratic socialism
to young young Americans that are prone
to democratic socialism I would say this
if you pursue my route as a hyper
capitalist you're gonna find 5% growth
rates over the next century and yeah
we'll figure out a way to innovate our
way out of climate change you saw my
question if you pursue his route you're
gonna get three point five percent
growth and that 1.5 percent difference
is a matter of life or death for
hundreds of millions of people all
around the world I mean but instead
we're getting this this this whole
inventing of language or what he's not
even defending what he's here to defend
that's lost capitalism you should go a
little musical in a capitalist society
I'm sorry your side has built a society
obviously we tried to humanize it and
change it over time but you're living in
a capital society this is this is your
look please this is a thing that
vegetarians certainly love you but
you're but why don't you just come on
stage and take
no no Gigi don't don't put that offer
out there alright we've unfortunately
run out of time we've run out of time
here for Q&A but they you so much for
the questions I just don't mind that
obviously we've got closing statements
now but this is a very heavy issue that
we're not gonna solve in an in a
two-hour debate so there is wine and
cheese and everything afterwards where
you can continue to ask questions both
of them will be around but we have not
finished we have no rapping we now have
our five minutes closing statements from
the affirmative Abbas Carson Cara if you
wanted to go ahead and close up your
site thank you all for sticking around
thank you for moderating this it's an
unenviable task and I really do
appreciate thank you to to Jean for the
for the invitation actually he was very
persistent in getting me here he did
everything organizing it you know he
even gave me the pen that I'm using in
the debate so he was very cordial
setting it up and whatever else I really
do appreciate it and I appreciate the
the audience yes
he literally ripped his notebook in half
to give me something that I press on it
right on so is it yeah ID appreciate it
now capitalism of course has proved
remarkably durable far beyond the
expectations of socialists you know 100
plus plus years ago but from a different
perspective the history of working-class
politics since the days of Marx and
Engels has in fact been a great success
you know god I'm once again mentioned
God rested on the seventh day the labor
movement gave us the sixth off we went
from an era when capital ruled
unchallenged to one with powerful limits
on its conduct the 40-hour week labor
and environmental regulations and more
these reforms and the broader progress
of women's liberation and towards racial
equality are constantly under siege but
they happen we don't as I said before
live in the worst of all possible worlds
the world we live in as brutal and
unequal as it is has been made more
humane by class-conscious movements by
the efforts of
Democratic socialists this consolation
seems like a small one given how lofty
our ambitions still are but many not
gene obviously would agree that you know
socialists have always understood that
capitalism works they even proved
capable reforming some of his ugly
features but why would we want to repeat
the disasters of 20th century the 20th
century but once again struggling to go
beyond it and create a social system
I've tried to offer in a series of
scattered and increasingly erratic
interventions a few answers to that
question now the first is that the
tremendous suffering in the world today
demands a response capitalist
development has created mass abundance
but it hasn't met the needs of the most
vulnerable millions still die every year
of preventable diseases many more spend
their lives mired in poverty the second
answer is as I mentioned ideological and
I'll admit that capitalism is based off
wage labor which rests on the
exploitation and domination of humans by
other humans democratic workplaces
embedded in an economy committed to the
moral Worth and flourishing of all could
make the subordination no longer
necessary a third answer even if we're
content to simply reform capitalism
these reforms will be continually
undermined by capital's structural power
addressing that dilemma will mean
pressing on to democratic socialism a
good social democracy can get us pretty
far along the road to justice and we
know that social democracy works and
presumably where it falls short it could
be improved without completely doing
away with private ownership but there's
more than an ideological motivation for
a radical socialism well I consider
myself a democratic social it's not a
social democrat more than the moral idea
that the exploitation of people by
people is a problem in desperate need of
a solution
capitalism both crates the precondition
for radical human flourishing and
prevents its ultimate fulfillment for
socialists
to the extent that some hierarchies
linger they have to be constantly
justified and held in check today I
think we would all agree that extreme
forms of slavery of exploitation like
slavery should be prohibited their
socialist argues that wage labor is an
acceptable form of exploitation and that
we actually have alternatives now to
empower ordinary people to control their
destinies inside and outside their
workplace but even I have a hard time
imagining that the abstractions of
ideology will be enough to encourage a
risky leap from a humane social the
Democratic world the world that we could
build into an unknown socialist one if
that happens I imagine it'll be driven
through practical necessity through the
day-to-day struggle to preserve and
expand reforms socialists have survived
a lot over the past century it survived
persecution from tyrants and the tyrants
that it itself gave birth to it survived
the radical reshaping of capitalism and
that of its great protagonists the
working-class but does socialism have a
future
well democratic socialism actually
prevail people to more free and
prosperous system I have the utmost
confidence that a world in which some
thrive by depriving others of freedom
billions needlessly suffer amid plenty
and we move closer to ecological
catastrophe is unacceptable I also
believe that as long as we live in a
society divided by class there will be a
national natural opposition to
inequality and exploitation there will
be technical and political barriers to
progress that we can't underestimate but
if we're to make something of our shared
homeland socialist politics broadly
conceived offers us the best tools for
getting there and to thinking about
what's wrong with capitalism today
[Applause]
now have five minutes summary from the
negative well when Bhaskar ducked some
of my questions this evening there was
at least one case in which I was
heartened that he did duck the question
because when I kept asking him in his
socialist society would he shut down
crowdfunding and make it unlawful and if
something's unlawful you get punished he
couldn't answer the question he felt
back on same solid jurisprudence but he
wants a social society in which private
ownership of the means of production is
not permitted so again if it's not
permitted it's unlawful if it's on it's
not unlawful you use the power of the
state to punish people who break that
law even let's slip well yeah maybe I
would allow cloud funding that was a
good sign then when I asked Bhaskar
would you make it unlawful for somebody
to work for me I work for him just on
whatever terms they choose and if you
don't want them to do the well it may
not be necessary he said to prevent them
well yes but if it were necessary what
would you do and and then to in answer
when I asked him what why would you want
the state-owned banks to be the only
forum well well maybe they're not such
ever well you know again we know I know
at least that Bhaskar Bhaskar once he
confronts the implications of what he's
really talking about is going to back
away from what he's really proposing the
outlawing of these practices because he
doesn't approve of them well the where
he ducked to my question continually and
where he kept insisting that somehow or
other this is not doable
he ducked my question by not realizing
that we in the 1970s realized that the
record of real socialism with a real
abolition of private owners
a means of production has been so
horrific that it's unimaginable the
millions do died on China the refreshin
in China the fact that the quasi
socialist Hugo Chavez most recently kept
being cited for human rights abuses I
didn't want to stick him with the
appalling record of socialism but what I
really want him to confront is this he
cannot keep talking about how well we're
going to evolve we're going to
experiment we're gonna see we don't know
we'll develop well unfortunately after a
century of Horrors from the record of
socialism we need better answers than
that and then most importantly we're
VASCAR backed away was when I kept
telling him that you can have the
socialist revolution to tomorrow you can
start it going
you don't need forcible government edict
top-down edict to bring about even at
best that will not be as socialism worth
having you should understand private
ownership of means of production offers
you all the opportunities you want to
create consumer economies that will only
buy from your worker owned companies so
they can run things the way they want
because the consumers of i from them
wanna buy from them you can take over
companies all of that potential bhaskar
kept backing away from and I only asked
him as a lover of freedom try to
confront that try to understand what
what what socialism through capitalist
means can offer him just as we in the
new left understood as well it's a very
difficult experiment
face it please call your own bluff bring
about the socialist economy quit
pretending that consumers that the
average person has no power when when
the bottom half had one-third of the
consumer dollar and the bottom
four-fifths have nearly two-thirds quit
pretending that there's no power when
three point two trillion dollars is is
controlled by pension funds that could
voluntarily not through force of elite
--ax quit pretending that they stayed on
banks that well it's been done and you
know it works fine and and the North
Dakotans love it quit pretending that
that should be the only stop in a free
society to to those who would tell us
that we have to abide by the decisions
of the majority over the state-owned
banks we freedom lovers including VASCAR
will have to say that no we understand
that you cannot have freedom without the
option of private ownership but the good
news the good news is that it not only
lifts the living standards of the broad
masses of people it offers the freedom
to practice socialism by capitalist
means bhaskar I invite you to learn that
and put your mind around it thank you
once again the resolution socialism
socialism is more effective than
capitalism in bringing freedom to the
masses so our results here the yes vote
beforehand it was 26 percent and
afterwards it was 30 percent we had a
change of three point seven percent that
is the score to beat here the no vote
started out at 52% and then it changed
to 63% so the change was 11 percent and
that means that the the winner here is
the no vote they picked up more points
there so the Tootsie Roll goes to Eugene
so well done the prestigious took the
role prize
[Applause]